a rare and historic move to tackle the
rising cost of gas in this country as
the war in ukraine drags on president
biden is draining nearly a third of
america's strategic oil reserve this is
the largest release ever
america will sell that oil on the open
market hoping to bring overall gas
prices down in the process energy costs
are a big reason of course for this
year's soaring inflation highest
inflation in 40 years
aaa is saying that the average price per
gallon is now four dollars and 22 cents
that is up
nearly 50 percent than a year ago more
than a dollar in most cases errol
barnett is in bethesda maryland with
more on the president's big decision era
a lot of people wondering is this going
to make a difference and when how soon
good morning
hey there tony good morning well already
u.s and international oil prices have
moved slightly lower following president
biden's major energy announcement which
is a small but positive sign that
announcement including the sizable
release from the strategic reserve to
get through what will be a
fuel-intensive summer but here's the
point drivers will still need to brace
themselves because there's no guarantee
that your gas tank will get dramatically
cheaper
if we want lower gas prices we need to
have more oil supply right now president
biden thursday announced an
unprecedented effort to ease the pain at
the pumps placing the blame for recent
hikes squarely on russia's war in
ukraine our prices are rising because of
putin's action there isn't enough supply
the plan includes releasing one million
barrels of oil every day through october
from the nation's strategic petroleum
reserve it'll have some impact but
perhaps not the impact that people
suspect oil analyst tom closer said
while drivers will see a modest dip in
prices they aren't plunging anytime soon
and how long do you think it will take
between this announcement and americans
seeing the result at the pump i think we
get a little bit of relief here in april
and may
but for memorial day to uh labor day
unfortunately we see very lumpy demand
and we'll see it lumpy on the high side
meanwhile today connecticut becomes the
latest state to try and soften the blow
of higher prices by suspending gas taxes
already drivers in georgia and maryland
are enjoying that relief i'm glad it's
going down a little bit now seems to be
making an improvement but patrick dehaan
of the fuel data website gas buddy says
the so-called tax holidays could
actually drive up prices in the long run
sheltering americans from the
consequences of high price could induce
more gasoline consumption could cause
gas prices to go up more dramatically
which could mean more traveling
adjustments like this i used to go where
i wanted to go now i go where i have to
go
it's true for so many people now just
yesterday chicago became the latest city
to offer these
free prepaid gas and transit cards to
help address these soaring prices that's
one other solution but all of the energy
analysts we've spoken with explained
that the global energy supply is so vast
so complicated with so many factors that
it could take a number of weeks before
we start to see any modest decrease in
prices here vlad
all right errol thank you very much
appreciate it